Greg Bell covers the Seahawks NFL writer
for The News Tribune takoma who joins us
now Greg thanks for joining us why was
Michael Bennett traded to the Eagles
well I been a lot of this salary reasons
and it's not a lot of money 2.2 million
the Seahawks days under the salary cap
but they're so up against the cap that
they need I mean that's one-sixth of
what they currently have in salary cap
space so he's 32 years old he played
through three injuries last year started
eight nets and a half sacks I don't buy
the argument that I've heard some people
assert that it's the Seahawks wanted to
eat quieter Pete Carroll Pete Carroll
enabled what Michael Bennett was in
Seattle the activism and the
outspokenness Michael Bennett was a
large reason why the Seahawks didn't
come out of the locker room in Tennessee
in that late September game after
President Trump's comments about
protesting NFL players he Carroll wanted
it to be that way he wanted his players
and still wants his players to be
outspoken it may have gotten a little
bigger than the Seahawks wanted but I
don't think that's the reason they sent
him out of town they had a chance to get
something for him rather than cut him
that something is not a lot of fifth
round pick and 1/4 wide receiver but but
there is no doubt the Eagles are getting
much more than a football player and
Michael Bennett what about Richard
Sherman's future in cm tenuous at best
now Dan the Seahawks have talked with
him about where to go next I understand
from sources telling you that he may
restructure his contract down from 11
million dollars due to him this year as
last year of his contract but the
Seahawks and Sherman haven't agreed on
whether they're going to go forward with
that plan he has no trade value at all
obviously is the lowest it's ever been
in his career because he's coming off a
two ankle surgeries
torn Achilles and a recent surgery on
his other Achilles and nobody's going to
give him more than a bag of kicking
piece for that even though he's a
three-time All Pro so it's either
cutting paying the 11 million or paying
less than the other million and those
are the decisions that both he who's
representing himself without an agent
and the Seahawks are going through right
now but we're also looking at this
Seattle team and that defense was still
pretty good even with all the injuries
last year it was the offense where it
felt like three and a half court
you would get nothing and then Pete
Carroll would just say to Russell Wilson
just improvise and you know try to help
us win a game can can they become an
offensive minded team in an offensive
minded league they have to become a run
minded being dammit and that that will
change that will be a change that in the
last couple of years of course they
don't have more so much anymore they
haven't had a running game really since
mark Simon's hung up the fleet's over
the wire and during the Superbowl 50 but
they need to get back to that Pete Rose
already mention that he's brought in a
new offensive coordinator and play
caller and Brian Schottenheimer who had
a number one rushing offense with the
Jets a decade ago he brought in a new
line coach fired Tom Cable and brought
in Mike Solari to completely change how
they evaluate and coach linemen there's
gonna be a run focus this year they
don't need and don't want Russell Wilson
to get 90% of their yards and all but
one rushing touchdown this year this
team had the lowest production from
running backs in the NFL in many years
this past season they need to upgrade
the running back position they did help
graves of people who block for him it's
Pete Carroll needs and wants to get back
to what he has won with in the past and
that's defense in a running game that
defense is getting older and is changing
too but there's no doubt that they
cannot survive offensively with just
number three running around making
improv plays all the time if the
escalator is going up or down for
Seattle it's gone down no doubt I mean
it was up for a long time though it was
a pretty high level for a while two
Super Bowls the end up the franchise's
first title five consecutive playoffs
this past season being the first time
miss in the playoffs in six years so no
doubt it's going down the Legion of boom
not 25 anymore than 30 they're sensitive
they're injured and that makes them
expendable they don't know if camp
Chancellor is coming back to play
because of neck injury cliff April is
probably going to retire because of neck
surgery well Thomas is entering the
summer this contract really now Dan this
team is Bobby Wagner on defense in
Russell Wilson on offense and oh by the
way Russell Wilson contract comes due
next year so they have a 30 plus million
dollar a year decision to make on him
and there's no doubt this teams in
transition Dan and they're looking up at
the Los Angeles Rams now instead of the
rest of the NFC West looking up at them
did she how I'll ever get over that
Super Bowl loss to New England many
players did not they believed that I
know especially on defense Bruce Irvin
was very vocal after liking you now in
Oakland but even guys like Michael
Bennett have in the back of their minds
that they believe the coaches cost them
a second consecutive ring and what many
people would have thought was one of the
best defenses in NFL history or one of
us in the last quarter century and if
you don't want to Super Bowl you don't
get that acclaim and a lot of players
believe that play call on the one-yard
line is the reason why they're not two
years in a row now everyone forgets to
remain curse making a ridiculous catch
throw they wouldn't even been down there
and just excited win the game but no
they're especially on defense those guys
feel like they had a second Super Bowl
being taken from them and that play well
as long as Mount Rainier stands out here
Dan that plays into remember does that
ultimately cost
Russell Wilson Hall of Fame he's still
27 28 years old it could if he never
gets back there and the NFL is as you
know cyclical that it's not a given that
you're going to contend for Super Bowls
all the time it seemed that way for four
or five years in Seattle but last year
was a reminder it's not that easy to get
back there it could if he never gets
back if he wins two Super Bowls in his
first four seasons the first three
seasons it was back then you know yeah
that's pretty impressive and I was just
one of many quarterbacks that have won
just one Super Bowl it's not a stretch
to say that could cost him down the line
it's so he won't cost him financially
though he's gonna make 30 plus many year
2019 and beyond no matter who plays for
but the Seahawks aren't gonna let him go
that's gonna be their focus next year
Greg good stuff thank you we appreciate
your joining us that's a Greg Bell
Seattle News Tribune Seahawks beat
reporter for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel two three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]